hey guys we are here at the Nintendo
switch hands on event in Hammersmith
London I'm tomorrow I'm joined by Oscar
hello we've just played Mario Kart 8
deluxe and I'm very excited about Mario
Kart everybody happy so what do you
think of it how do you feel to play
Mario Kart 8 switch well surprisingly it
felt very very similar to America 8 on
the way you
who'da guessed it is that a good thing
because you know it's almost a boat yeah
exactly it's Mario Kart 8 which is
amazing but it's horrible so I'm pretty
happy but if you're expecting a
revolutionary overhaul of merica you
might be disappointed I mean it's it's
fair to not to expect too much given
that it's called Mario Kart 8 at the
same time some people might be thinking
you know the switch there's a lot of new
things in comes up odd where does Mario
Kart 8 do anything with that
and it seems like no it seems like the
answer is no unfortunately for me it
looks on par with the Wii U version
maybe a tiny bit worse if you're really
really wincing see I played a decent
amount of Mario Kart 8 and so when I was
playing a switch version it looks
roughly right to me I look I'm kind of
like then scrutinize it too much and
they've looked colorful in the vibrant
on the screen
and so I was like yeah it looks fine to
me but you played quite a lot more of
Mario Kart I'm a massive merica you know
I will nitpick
until the cows come home and according
to you I think it looks a tiny bit worse
but on the other hand so that's made up
for the fact that it is portable you can
play it with there's so many people away
from the TV and when you say attorney
bill worked it's not to the point where
it's like detracting from your
experience absolutely absolutely yes
they're all like really smooth as well
like that's the main thing it to me it's
far more important to be smooth I'm
really playable there for it to look
amazing and it still does look amazing
tomorrow pee it's one of the best
looking games I'm please perfectly fine
yeah it's a fun it's one of the best
Mario cards in in a long time absolutely
yeah and the new stuff is the paddle
board right that's right yes so America
I did have a battle mode but it was just
in shorter versions of the main tracks
this time they've actually put battle
arenas in the game so we got to try one
of them which was censoring splatoon it
was really cool it looks exactly like
the splatoon map it's got being
splatters everywhere on the floor the
the inkling boy an inkling girl or in
the game now as well so if you really
want you can pretend it's Mattoon but
with carts yeah cuz then paint effect
you're kind of like physics are you
slipping or anything I was trying that
and I couldn't get it to I was really
hoping it would like the oil slicks and
as far as I could tell it was just a bit
of set dressing but it was really good
set dressing and like you said there are
new characters we didn't play any other
characters no it was an inkling boy
inkling girl I so junior jr. and
jingo for those are the new characters
is there anything else you knew and Mary
oppa not really I mean that's sort of
yeah okay yeah it's like I mean it's
coming out in April I believe is that
right that's right month after the
switch launches yeah so like you'll have
Legend of Zelda to keep you going until
Mary Fi and Mary quite a is a kind of
like a good pour ballgame right no
replies a good portable gaming to have
eight four voice blow I mean you only
have to look at the popularity of say
America at the s it's that but Mario
Kart 8 which is in my opinion the best
Mario Kart the time so I think Oscar
says it's the best marine corps ball
turn you can flame him on today if you
disagree where can we find you on to her
at they said it's a horrible name I'm at
my age and for more news videos about
new kind of switch keep it on gamespot
[Music]